نعم بالفعل العمليه العسكريه متواصله حتى
هذه اللحظه قبل قليل وصلت تعزيزات عسكريه
اسرائيليه جديده من محوري المحور الشمالي
بوابه شويكا وايضا المحور الغربي بوابه
1004 لتزداد عدد الاليات العسكريه
المقتحمه لمدينه طول كرم في هذه الليله
حيث تم رصد ما يزيد عن 35 اليه عسك عسكريه
وصلت الى مخيم نور شمس من عده محاور من
الجهه الشماليه وايضا من المحور الغربي
والمحور الجنوبي منطقه حاجز الطيبه وايضا
حي ذ النابه الى الجنوب من المخيم حيث
تقدمت او تقدم عدد كبير من الجنود
الراجلين نحو المخيم من منطقه ذنابه وصولا
الى بعض المنازل حيث تم مداهمه عدد من هذه
المنازل في الحي الجنوبي من مخيم نور شمس
التزامن مع ذلك كان هناك وصول او وصلت
تعزيزات عسكريه جديده من حاجز 104 وايضا
الحاجز الشمالي وهو بوابه 100
بوابه بلده او حي شويكا الى الشمال من
المدينه وصلت الى بالفعل الى مخيم نور شمس
بدات الاشتباكات المسلحه تدور في محيط
المخيم الاحتلال اعلن واغلق كافه مداخل
المخيم ليعلن بشكل رسمي عن مخيم نور شمس
نقطه عسكريه مغلقه يمنع التحرك فعليا في
المخيم وفي اجواء المخيم وفي محيط المخيم
ايضا ولم يقتصر فقط على هذا المخيم
الاليات العسكريه لا تزال تحاصر كافه
المحاور القريبه من مخيم نور شمس بالتزامن
مع ذلك كان هناك اقتحام ولا يزال متواصل
لعدد من الاحياء في مدينه طول كرم ووسط
حصار مشدد لجيش الاحتلال في مستشفى ثابت
ثابت الحكومي وايضا مستشفى الزكاء غرب
المدينه حيث يفرض الاحتلال الطوق الامني
ايضا على تلك المستشفيات
يمنع الاسعاف ومركبات الاسعاف من الخروج
او الدخول الى المستشفى حتى هذه اللحظه
وسط الاشتباكات التي لا تزال متواصله قوات
الاحتلال حاولت في هذه الاثناء وقبل قليل
اغلاق ايضا محيط الم شف وتحديدا المداخل
المتاخمه للمستشفى لمخيم او من المستشفى
لمخيم طولكرم ايضا وسط الاشتباكات التي لا
تزال متواصله حتى هذه اللحظه يذكر ان
الاقتحام الاخير كان لمخيم نور شمس هو قبل
اربع ايام فقط حيث كان خلالها تدمير لعدد
كبير من الطرقات والبنى التحتيه في داخل
مخيم نور شمس وايضا تدمير لعدد من المنازل
بفعل جرافات الدينين التي قام الاحتلال
وتعمد الاحتلال خلال الاقتحام الاخير
بتمريرها من داخل ازقه المخيم الضيقه
لتدمير الجدران او جدران المنازل اثناء
هذا المرور على صعيد اليوم وميدانيا لا
يزال الاحتلال يفرض الحصار وسط اشتباكات
مسلحه عدد الاليات العسكريه التي اقتحمت
المدينه توحي بان العمليه العسكريه لربما
ستتواصل لاكثر من يوم هذا حقيقه لا نستطيع
ان نحدده في هذه الاثناء لكن الساعات
القادمه كفيله
بتحديد ماهيه هذا الاقتحام والاهداف التي
يسعى الاحتلال لها من خلال هذا الاقتحام
لمخيم نور شمس بالتزامن ايضا مع هذا
الاقتحام هناك اقتحامات متواصله لجيش
الاحتلال لمدن الضفه الغربيه المحتله حيث
اقتحمت مدينه الخليل وبعض الاحياء في
مدينه الخليل ونحن يعني نتحدث حث في
الساعات الاولى من هذه الليله اي ان
الاقتحامات لربما خلال الساعات القادمه
ستزداد في مدن الضفه الغربيه المحتله على
غرار ما حدث خلال الليله الفائته في مدن
الضفه الغربيه والايام السابقه عمليا ليث
حينما تعلن حينما تعلن قوات الاحتلال مخيم
نور شمس في طول كرم منطقه عسكريه مغلقه
وتفرض حظرا للتجول ماذا يجري تحديدا بناء
على هذه الاعلانات او هذا هذا
التحرك نعم يعني بناء على ذلك الاحتلال
يقوم
ب عبر مكبرات الصوت في الاعلان بشكل رسمي
ان للمواطنين الفلسطينيين بمنع الخروج
رسميا من المنازل ايضا يفرض حصار واسع على
الاحياء المتواجده في هذه المناطق التي
التي اعلن خلالها او من خلال هذه العمليه
الاغلاق الواسع وا يعني منع التحرك
للمواطنين من خلال ذلك ايضا يعني من
الممكن ان يطلق النار صوب اي جسم متحرك في
المنطقه عندما يعلن ان هذه المنطقه نقطه
عسكريه مغلقه ويمنع التحرك بها من المنطقه
هذا يعني ان انه من الممكن ان يطلق النار
وفي هذه اللحظات يعني لربما المصور يرصد
تقدم لبعض الاليات العسكريه نحو هذه
المنطقه في هذه اللحظات نعم بالفعل هناك
تقدم في هذه اللحظات لبعض الاليات
العسكريه القادمه من محيط مخيم نور شمس
باتجاه المنطقه الشماليه الغربيه للمدينه
اي ان الاحتلال في كل اقتحام عمد الى ايه
افراغ اليات العسكريه التي تصل الى مخيم
نور شمس من الجنود الراجلين ومن ثم العوده
الى بوابه
104 مجددا ومره اخرى
ليتم ال يعني ليقوم الاحتلال خلال ذلك
ب يعني اعاده تعبئه الاليات العسكريه
بالجنود ومن ثم الانسحاب من ذلك او من
المنطقه على الفور في هذه اللحظات بالفعل
الاليات العسكريه بدات بالتقدم نحو هذه
المنطقه ولربما سنرصد تحرك وتقدم الاليات
العسكريه التي ستصل تباعا في هذه اللحظات
نحو هذه ال المنطقه نعم اذا تقدم بالفعل
للاليات العسكريه طارك عندك دير بالك نعم
تقدم للاليات العسكريه في هذه اللحظات
ولربما
نرصد وصول لهذه الاليات اذا اذا لم يكن من
المامون بالنسبه لك الوقوف في هذا المكان
فيعني لك ان تتوخى الحذر وان تبحث عن
منطقه اكثر
امنا نعم نعم الان بالفعل على ما يبدو ان
الاليات
العسكريه بدات
بالوصول نحو هذه
المنطقه ربما المصور
يرصد هذه
الاليات التي تصل في هذه اللحظات على ما
يبدو انها قامت
ب يعني تم مشاهده بعض
المواطنين الذين يتواجدون في هذه اللحظات
في هذه المنطقه فقامت بالتوقف
وللتاكد مما سيحدث او من هم الاشخاص
الذين وقفوا في هذه المنطقه نعم بالفعل
الان تصل هذه الاليات العسكريه نعم عدد من
الاليات العسكريه في هذه اللحظات ثلاثه
اليات عسكريه تصل الى المنطقه الشماليه
الغربيه من المدينه بالفعل هي عائده من
مخيم نور شمس باتجاه بوابه 104 لتقوم با
اعاده
تحميل الجنود ومن ثم ارسالهم بالفعل الى
مخيم نور شمس في هذه اللحظات هذه المنطقه
قبل قليل حدث فيها
انفجارات يعني عده من قبل المقاومه
الفلسطينيه حيث اطلقوا عدد من العبوات
الناسفه نحو الاليات العسكريه فبالتالي
يسعى الاحتلال من خلال الوصول او حيث يصل
الى هذه المنطقه للتاكد من انها خاليه من
المواطنين ومن العبوات الناسفه التي من
الممكن ان تستهدف الاليات العسكريه اثناء
مرورها من هذا الطريق تم رصد مجموعه من
الشبان فبالتالي وقف الاحتلال في هذه
المنطقه للتاكد من ايه مما سيحدث او
سيفعله هؤلاء ال الشبان في هذه المنطقه
بعد التاكد من ان المنطقه تخلو او خاليه
من العبوات الناسفه تقدمت هذه الاليات
باتجاه المنطقه الشماليه الغربيه نم وصولا
الى بوابه 104 لاعاده تحميل الجنود ومن ثم
ارسالهم الى مخيم نور شمس